are we alone in the universe I think the
balance of probability is that we are
not alone um if we are alone in the
universe then that has interesting
implications it means that the origin of
Life on our planet was a supremely
improbable event so improbable that
we're probably wasting our time trying
to work out how it happened but I don't
believe that and I I do actually believe
that we are one of many life forms in
the universe and I would love to know
what what the others are like there's a
big distinction between life and
intelligent life intelligent life if we
ever encounter it we'll almost certainly
encounter it not physically because the
distances will be too great um but we
would most likely to meet them through
radio waves they have actual dishes
pointing out looking for signs of
intelligent
life